[Music]
you know nat i congratulate you because
you have a fantastic story all right
you've been uh struggling in the
business a lot of people have to start
they have to struggle a little bit yeah
you get uh you win on oscar not long ago
yes uh months ago right you went nine
months ago so you win an oscar and the
next day
you were cast
on this show that everybody really liked
yeah it's kind of absurd like kind of
like
my neurotic brain sort of kicked in you
know and then you're sort of like
terrified like that you're gonna then
the next like too many good things have
happened you know so like the next thing
you're gonna like be naked in a gutter
like you know doing meth you know like
half naked maybe that sounds like
another good thing
why do you judge these things that's a
good call a third awesome thing
uh yeah it's funny because i i i went i
was talking to uh backstage we were just
chatting a little bit and i swear to god
i detected as i thought i detected a
slight boston accent in the area is this
true yeah this is true all right now
you're you're from boston i grew up in
boston and i moved away uh you know
when after college but i'm i was curious
i had when i look at old
uh home movies with me i've got a boston
accent yeah like when i was a kid i'm
like yeah
yeah you know and then
i don't know that was like who that was
uh
but it kind of just went away on its own
from living in so many other cities yes
no i have that same thing like if i'm
around my friends like there's like a
strong and there's only like a few words
that you end up using like when you're
around people like when you're around
friends from boston yeah it's basically
like i use the words like uh lit and
hurt and it's just like dude you're
gonna get lit tonight yeah dude i'm hurt
yeah i'm so hurt but i'll probably get
lit again yeah
but where did you grow up in boston like
i'm from brooklyn
yeah why few well just because i grew up
in in a town called manchester by the
sea oh yeah and there's like really
which is a beautiful town but there's
really nothing like super tough about it
you know because it's like four hyphens
in the name and so like i'll see other
people from boston out here you know
like at a sports bar like watching the
socks or something and they'll come up
and they'll be like oh snap oh dude you
know sully mike get over here dude this
kid's from boston nah dude oh my god
like where are you from and i'm like oh
well um yeah i'm just from the north
shore where you guys from like ah like
malden revere like natick like oh that's
also you know roxbury yeah roxbury oh
these are like tough places
and yeah like where are you from dude
and you're like
i'm usually like i just you know and
then i try to think of like other tough
like towns that are near it you know
like gloucester adjacent you know or
danvers
and they just started looking like no
but beware dude you know and then i'm
like
manchester by the sea
[Applause]
it also just sounds like you should turn
and this should be like art music i'm
from manchester by the sea
i know
like it's not my fault it's not a tough
sounding name you know no no but you
live with it no idea you have persevered
you have you and your writing partner uh
win uh yeah uh win oscars yeah this is a
great honor for for helping to write the
descendants yes and um
there was this great moment your writing
partner you all get up on stage and your
writing partner uh mocked the pose that
angelina jolie had done in her dress and
it became actually the most probably the
most memorable moment of the night i
think we have the photograph of that he
was yeah
did he just did he just think to do that
at the moment he's such a dick like
such a big move
now i know you're from boston yeah yeah
no it's such a big move like we were
walking up there and we're both like oh
my god i can't believe this just
happened and we walk up you know and
then
there's like this pause because you know
we sort of knew that we weren't going to
speak alexander payne was going to sort
of do the talking and so we were
standing there and then there was like
this delayed laughter and so i look over
and jim's doing the pose and i'm like
you son of a like that's amazing like
why did you not tell me we were gonna
you know like we should have done it
together you know so then to like try to
like play catch up like i
i tried to do the pose too and like in
my mind i think i thought that we were
doing the exact same thing like his his
was like this right right so in my mind
i'm like we're both doing it the crowd
is loving it like this is killing but in
actuality like when i went back and like
looked at it later like it literally
just looks like i'm i'm just like
enjoying his pose with my like leg open
like i'm just awkwardly standing like
sort of an effeminate way like
hips out like you're doing it jim
just nothing
that's so weak then you run into your
boston friends dude dude
get the hell out of here